normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government here's
a story from the post-millennial
far-left BLM activist John Sullivan
convicted on all charges in the January
6th case Sullivan said he was only at
the capital to document the event this
is really interesting because uh he's a
prominent BLM activist who was there
during court testimony he said he was
only there to document I was only
observing I followed the crowd I'm here
to document San's testimony was followed
up by prosecutors who played multiple
videos of Sullivan urging on the mob
which included a self de declaration to
make Trump supporters fish up I'm going
to side with anyone who is ready to rip
this ish down Sullivan said in one video
I brought my megaphone to instigate ish
he said in another video NBC news
reports that prosecutors portrayed Sven
as an anti-establishment activist who
had the goal to burn it all down now I
have to wonder here's NBC news saying
anti-establishment activists sought to
incite Trump supporters on January 6 doj
argues but of course I want to make sure
we can bring up John Earl Sullivan's
Wikipedia page he's got one where they
mention he organized and participated in
protest relating to Black lives matter
though a few other BLM organizers
explicitly disavowed him I don't think
that matters that's what the his his
ideology was they say he entered the
capital and accidentally broke a window
he repeatedly shouted encouragement to
fellow Riders and they go on to outright
outline the things that uh uh he he he
he does and ultimately his claims of
being a journalist I believe CNN paid
him or what do they 50 Grand something
like that for his footage had him on TV
here's what's fascinating here's why I
think they're not calling him far left
for one there's absolutely NBC News
they're they're super biased but we're
talking about a federal federal charge
here I'm I'm I'm curious actually I
believe it is DC right are you going to
convict a black lives matter supporter
on January 6 by telling a jury that this
guy was a black lives matter supporter
and so the strategy of the prosecutors
is if we go to the jury and say BLM they
acquit him and if they acquit him then
they got to quit everybody well so so
he's just being the charges are being
brought against him right he hasn't been
convicted convicted on all oh he was
convicted okay my mistake okay and then
do you have does it say anything about
like what obviously hasn't been
sentenced yet but what type of jail time
he's looking at for this uh well here's
the interesting thing I mean because
breaking a window is what that uh the
proud boy or whatever got that got him
like 15 17 years or whatever it was and
they the arent was that they were like
well by breaking a window this wasn't
just oh you broke a government window it
was you created an opening for a mob
that would then be trying to overthrow
the government so I'm just saying what
cuz for the record whatever this guy arm
well whatever this guy was armed on arm
armed a knife and they even point out
that he drew the knife in on the house
wait wait he he drew his knife as Riders
were trying to breach the house floor
well I didn't realize this guy was a
hero I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
that's a joke YouTube It's a total joke
and I don't mean that literally but you
know get my point anyway um well I'm
just saying what like I because if
they're going first off if they're going
to throw the book at this guy in that
way I still would think that's insane as
I do with all the January 6 protesters
what's really interesting about this is
the question of which I don't know if
it's clear what is this guy hey I'm just
so anti-establishment I'm a burn it all
down when there's black lives matter
rally guy and I'mma burn it all down
when there's j6 type guys or is this
what I think a lot of the right Wingers
were more suspicious of initially after
January 6th that this is somebody who's
trying to make the prot Trump movement
look bad by instigating all of them to
do something that then could be spun as
like yeah look how horrible the pro
Trump people are could be both because
if if black lives matter was disavowing
this guy before the January 6 thing even
went off he might have been kill two
birds with one stone situation where
he's like yo I can f the government and
I can get all these people thrown in
jail and get them to commit crimes and
then I can you know do away with two
know he just sounds like a radical that
went too far I don't know if you guys
remember this but prior to January of
2021 the left was not shy about openly
embracing insurrectionist rhetoric I
remember during the BLM rights there
were left wiers who were saying all
these right-wing Hypocrites spent years
saying they have the Second Amendment to
rebel against tyranny and overthrow the
US government and now that the
government is just indiscriminately
killing unarmed black people which is of
course a lie but that's what they were
saying these right- wiers won't rise up
against this state and then as soon as
January uh 6th 2021 happens oh my gosh
Insurrection is the most serious problem
in this country and we need to call
these people Traders and throw them in
prison so it wouldn't surprise me that
you actually might have a left-wing
activist saying yeah I'll join with
these right- Wingers try to overthrow
the government or try to instigate
instigate right-wingers to overthrow the
government I want to crank this thing
all the way up to 11 right now if I may
and just say Civil War all right
everybody's been waiting I haven't said
it in a few months so I feel like I'm
it's it's due but no let me explain I I
don't literally mean to say sa but I'd
like for you guys to give me your
thoughts on the other day we saw David
deap testify this is the guy who
attacked Paul Pelosi in his testimony he
claimed that he was a leftist who was
radicalized by right-wing conspiracy
theories watching YouTube of that he
included me glenbeck James Lindy dases
toza made a good point that this is a
narrative where they go to them and say
they go to these these people who are
being charged like the J Sixers and say
blame Trump blame the right and do this
I think there's a really simple reason
why that's the case you're in San
Francisco you are in The Bluest of blue
and the defense says to you listen you
will not win because you attacked Paul
poosi however the best sympathy you will
get is if you claimed you were
radicalized by the far right and that
you you oh no what if they done to me
it's the evil right that did it try and
earn some sympathy in that way the
reason why they're arguing this guy in a
federal case in DC is anti-establishment
and not farle once again is for that
exact same reason now what happens is
you are you are getting through these
high-profile cases in San Francisco I'm
seeing these people post saying oh look
James Lindsay Tim pool glenbeck oh they
they radicalize this guy it's a lie it's
nonsense and but it's creating that
terrifying Boogeyman it's creating that
bifurcation if prosecu prosecutors in
high-profile cases are keep are they're
going to keep playing this Narrative of
Donald Trump is radicalizing people to
extremes anytime someone commits an some
kind of extreme act even a BLM supporter
they're going to blame the far right or
the quote unquote far right they're
creating a a narrative that young people
who are entering the political space
will believe we live in this world so
real quick as an example it's a really
it's a really interesting point that you
bring up I can I just say like because I
think that's such a good point and such
an interesting thing to to focus on
because like as a as a Libertarian um
one of the things that we talk about a
lot is that like look we we don't think
government should be in the business of
kind of micromanaging culture and things
like this but you also recognize that
you need other forces like you need kind
of a virtuous culture in order for that
to work and I think one of the things
I've been thinking this a lot like since
all these uh these insane indictments
have been coming down against Donald
Trump when you look at like kind of the
landscape of current day America you go
how could a guy like Donald Trump ever
get a fair trial I mean if you have a
jury trial with Donald Trump whoever the
jury pool is it's like a 5050 shot that
they either think he is Jesus or Satan
and how could how could anyone who has
either one of those opinions ever be an
honest juror and I think kind of the
point you're making here is that like
look in the reality today of a modern
jury trial with the polarization of the
country and this white hot culture War
you almost yeah man if you're on trial
in San Francisco it's almost like the
only way to tailor your defense is to
try to have it something that hugs a
left-wing sympathy let me let me add to
what you said you said 5050 let's say 33
but no no no no here's what I mean 33%
are say Trump's Hitler 33 are going to
say Trump is good and 33 are going to
say holy crap I better side with the
left otherwise antifa is going to show
to my
house fair enough but but it's an
interesting point right because people
who were uh charged in relationship to
January 6th they because of activities
they engaging on January 6 are tried in
Washington DC as if that's a jury of
their peers I'm sorry if you came from
Arkansas DC leftists are that's not a
jury of your peers that's
people exactly people with a specific
political bias who hate you in your way
of life hold on I mean think about what
you're saying here other Americans are
your enemies oh boy so so when I'm not
other Americans people in Washington DC
let's be clear about this but I get it
but like the the the the genuine
sentiment is if you are from look I
brought this up yesterday when we were
talking about the toap thing we had a
legal issue against a major corporation
and my lawyer said okay well if you sue
in California or New New York you'll
lose the the Democrat judge is already
going to hate you Tim Po and outside of
that they're going to be way more Pro
corporate and they're not going to care
about your rights you sue in West
Virginia you're going to win overnight
why well you're in West Virginia they
like you Tim poool and I'm like is that
really all that it is
yes selecting the proper venue is the is
like one of the most important things
especially today if not the most
important thing I have I have a bit of a
different angle on this I think that the
uh the the real concern that I have is
that you have these commentators that
are being categorized like you're my
friend Tim here along with James Lindsay
and others that they're trying to kind
of lay out the groundwork for this
stochastic terrorism argument where
you're being uh you know pushed into
radicalism by people who are just
speaking freely and then you're now in
some in some way uh what's it what's the
word
exul where basically you're you're
personal responsibility is removed
because you've been inspired by this
radical Tim P or Alex Jones or whatever
and it just it really because of the
where we're at that that's a real thing
and like they've come at you before with
that wasn't what was the other that
Young Turk
uh chick tried to like come at you about
how uh some shoter liked one of your
videos or something like that no not
Young Turks I'm
sorry that was the guy in Texas who uh
on his Facebook had posted four
screenshots of one episode and one
specific portion of one episode and it
actually showed he wasn't a subscriber
which is it's such a crazy thing because
when you have a show like look like you
have a show like with this size audience
which you've built up a very big
platform here the idea that any one
person who one time liked one clip on
this you're now on the it's literally
it's almost on the level of like well
this this Mass shooter watched Friends I
mean well I think I think obviously Ross
and Rachel are the reason why he shot up
that but the other thing about it that's
crazy is that was the one that
radicalized when you yeah I I'll tell
you she's the one it was on that show
she was the one but like if you actually
kind of live in this world of like I do
consider myself to be a radical
politically speaking I'm pretty
radically outside of what the current
status quo is but when you're in this
world it's kind of my uh my my good
friend Michael malice good friend of the
show he used to always say and I really
loved this uh when he would go I hope
left wiers understand that the NRA are
the moderates on this issue cuz it
really is like if you're not in that
world I know they painted as like that's
like the crazy extreme that's a there
the NRA is up there like all we need to
do is enforce existing gun laws
and you're like wow that's so extreme
and you're like extreme is like shell
not infringe yes like but the point is
that if you're actually talking about a
radical show like a show and I'm not
even not radical in the way I am I'm
radically like nonviolent and peaceful
if you were talking about a show that
was going to amp you up to go like
murder people this is not that show
there's crazy people out there on the
internet and this is not that real quick
question do you think individual
citizens have the right to keep and bear
biological weapons
well we're getting a little out there
with biological weapons i' say down i'
say well it depends on what the
biological weapon is how it's I mean uh
I it depends on exactly what your
definition of that is I draw my line at
nukes uh no I'm just kidding uh well you
no look I think if you were to have this
is a serious
question I will say unequivocally the
Constitution Pro uh guarantees our right
to keep in bare arms it doesn't Define
what arms are private citizens to this
day own nuclear weapons through their
corporations and back then owned
warships nothing's changed yeah so right
now to this day it's not even
controversial to say except in the in
these podcasts liberals get shocked that
I would say this and I'm like do you
think Ron is a government operation yes
no look so in that case you're
absolutely right there could be an
argument made that if you were uh if you
were possessing uh chemical weapons and
were keeping them like in a in a very
risky way that could hurt a lot of other
people then you should be maybe liable
for the fact that you're putting other
people at risk but in theory in theory I
would tend to agree with you this is the
argument they make about proper gun
storage and stuff like this like you can
only have a gun if it's separate from
the ammo and in your trunk and not in
your you know not in the same yeah so
then the question is where you do draw
the line but at the same point if you
had a gun that you left out that the
difference between like a nuke or or
chemical weapons and a gun is that a
nuke if you're just keeping it in a way
where it could just detonate at any
moment is actually a threat to other
people whereas a gun someone actually
has to pick it up and point the trigger
and shoot anyway I'm all for no no
restrictions brandishing a weapon if
you're like waving it around at people
on wrongly so you could you could think
maybe there's don't try to out Anarchist
metim I'm not going to lose this B I
will I will say let me just say real
quick I I I do agree with the sentiment
obviously I don't want the government
regulating any Weaponry that I can own
however I go the opposite direction
where I say uh Humanity ought to be
working towards nuclear disarmament
broadly speaking so I'm not interested
in having civilians have them I'm more
interested in getting the federal
government to have far less
the goal should be to disarm Federal
governments that should be the goal yes
I think every every person on the planet
should have a a nuke perhaps a MV with
you know a 12 Warhead MV and because a
nuclear armed individual an individually
nuclear armed Society is is a very
polite I'm kidding I am kidding
extraordinarily polite extraord or
glowing either way it's a have you read
John John lot's book more nukes less
crime it's uh it's good a lot of good
stats in there anyway what were we
talking about before I decided to ask
about that uh January 6 talking about
the courts and how the courts have
basically turned into if you're in a
conservative District you know what a
leftist is going to get a fair trial not
as as Fair as like it's hard to say fair
fair um a leftist in a conservative
district is going to get a decent trial
definitely trial is going to get
feathered strung up for for jayw walking
or farting Donald Trump could fart in
public and they're going to get him on
some nonsense and and lock him up the
truth the truth is that that left is
Dogma is is so much a prerequisite for
all of Academia at this point if you if
you have to rely on any Institution for
your freedom you're in a lot of trouble
at this point yeah politically in in
Academia obviously now in the Judiciary
as well it it's not getting any better
either because they have had a hundred
years of infiltration into these uh you
know mind creation uh institutions so
yeah we're we have an uphill battle I
think the like the only caveat and I
agree with what you're saying Tim I
think there is there there is a point
there that it's not equal kind of on on
both sides but I guess part of the
difference there too is that look there
is let's say in rightwing or red America
I think there is a tremendous amount and
I would argue justifiably but a
tremendous amount of like resentment
towards say the political establishment
the de particularly the Democratic party
establishment so the the thing is I
don't I don't know that in this moment
of this hot culture War I don't know
that Hillary Clinton could get a fair
trial in rural Alabama but the thing is
that Hillary Clinton is never going to
face charges in rural Alabama right like
the the federal government or different
state governments or different like if
there were some like conservative
financier who's financing you know
conservative prosecutors is never right
this just doesn't exist and then and
Hillary Clinton isn't going to ever be
put in that situation whereas Donald
Trump will be on trial in New York City
in Washington DC and so that that is
part of the asymmetry also is that the
entire like ruling base of the
establishment is on one side of this you
know people say like oh the red pill is
that people who have information that
will lead to the arrest of Hillary
Clinton die actually the red pill is no
amount of information will ever lead to
the arrest of Hillary Clinton there is
nothing you could show anybody that
would ever woman a day in court yeah
that's a big cope that you think at the
end of this you know whatever the Q
andon
craziest Jack kened is coming back
Roseanne has a standing bet with Michael
males two of them one is that there will
not be an election so we're looking
forward to that and that there will be
military tribunals by the end of the
year which I I don't know if if she
talking about this year or what but uh
you know we'll see she has right about
everything let's but but you know to be
honest she made a good point though cuz
I asked her to clarify on this I said
are you saying we all just skip election
day the TV says no elections or are you
saying that something changes the
election fundamentally to the point
where it's a sham like North Korea's
elections M well case we didn't have an
election in 2020 well or 2016 look I'll
say as and I say this uh disclaimer I
love rosan I consider her like a comedy
icon and every time I've met her I'm
giddy in the room that I'm even in her
presence and she's just hilarious and so
great but perhaps a little bit more of a
serious voice on this uh topic is
Colonel Douglas McGregor y who also said
he is I don't know exact exactly what he
said but he basically said that he is
very concerned that there will not be a
democratic election in 2024 now I'd like
to hope he's he's wrong about that um he
wasn't
wrong can can we break down what does
that mean does that mean and this is the
important question we had with Roseanne
does that mean there's no polling
stations the TV just says you're not
voting or does it mean it's going to be
uh Donald Trump removed from the ballot
and then 75 million people feel like
they're not allowed to vote at all
because of this well I don't know I mean
I have no idea it's not my prediction
but I think what uh if I remember
correctly this was on Patrick B David
show he said this Colonel Douglas
McGregor that is who's been right about
a lot of stuff over the last 20 years
and um I think he was basically saying
that some type of emergency is going to
be declared uh and that that is going to
that it's going to be used as an excuse
to like postpone indefinitely the next
election now again I'm not claiming this
is going to happen but I will say that I
if that sounds crazy to you just take a
step back look at the last three and a
half years in America and go look a lot
of things sound the idea of lockdowns
would have sounded really crazy in
2019 and you know that happened if you
talk to yourself from 2014 you were like
all right so here's what's going to
happen Donald Trump's going to be
elected president and then the Deep
State's going to try to unseat Donald
Trump when he's the president of the
United States because he's trying to
dismantle the industrial military
complex and get us out of all of these
Foreign Wars and then what's going to
happen is there's going to be a virus
that was created through research funded
by the United States that'll be released
and everyone's going to be locked in
their homes the econom is going to crash
and we're going to have rampant
inflation and then people are going to
be debating whether the election was
still You' be like what are you talking
about but also the FBI c will be working
against Donald Trump the entire time
they'll be lying to him about troop
counts in Syria we'll have a bunch of
different fronts for nuclear for World
War II yeah it's this is all going to
happen in the next five years thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at
timcast.net exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next
time